will clemente can't join us today so
instead you got me and we're gonna go
through all the on-chain metrics that
we'll put together we're gonna talk
through why the hell is bitcoin's price
crashing what the hell is going on well
first and foremost is that bitcoin has
now hit an all-time high correlation to
nasdaq the reason why that's important
is because there is not necessarily a
catalyst on the horizon that is going to
lead to more inflows into bitcoin as an
asset and so bitcoin is at the mercy of
risk-off assets for the time being as
those risk assets get sold by wall
street and other types of investors due
to the fed's interest rate hikes that
are believed to be happening in 2022
bitcoin is also being sold off if you
look around in your portfolio and you
are a professional investor if you're an
institutional investor and you say to
yourself i need to get back into some
sort of value stocks or i need to get
into more conservative assets you're
going to sell your technology stocks
you're going to sell bitcoin etc that
may be different than what bitcoiners
themselves who treat bitcoin as a
reserve asset are doing but what we see
is that on wall street in many of these
institutions we are seeing that they are
treating bitcoin the same as nasdaq and
you see that directly with the all-time
high of bitcoin and nasdaq correlation
so pretty incredible to see that there
now of course bitcoin continues to fall
as well and so if we look at bitcoin's
net realized profit loss exactly what
are people doing are they selling at a
loss or are they selling at a profit
well what the blockwear team has looked
at is that capitulation seems to be
slowing for now meaning that there's a
decreasing amount of losses being
realized and what you can see here is
that that red whenever it is very very
deep below the zero dollar line people
are selling at a loss but as we see a
recovery back towards zero it means less
and less people are selling at a loss
and so at the end of december and in the
beginning of january there was tons of
people selling at a loss but now we are
returning back to zero kind of a break
even point usually that ends up meaning
that we'll go back to anyone who sells
after we've crossed back over zero it's
all at a profit so paying attention to
this is important because ultimately
capitulation happens when somebody holds
an asset it goes down and rather than
hold until it comes back they simply
capitulate they say i'm done i'm just
willing to sell it at a loss i'm going
to go invest my money somewhere else so
capitulation seems to be slowing for now
if we then look at the percent supply in
profit you can see that that is only
around 70 or so you can see right here
in this chart and so that is about the
same level that we saw over the summer
when we actually bottomed out before
having a massive recovery again that
does not mean that we were gonna get an
exact repeat of that drawdown but in
march april and may of 2021 we were up
in the 50 60 000 uh mark of bitcoin we
then drew down from that point more than
50 percent down to about 30 000 or so
and then of course that percent supply
and profit was hovering just under 70
it then led to a massive move back all
the way up to the all-time high of 69
000
well now as the price has sold off again
where do we find ourselves we find
ourselves again right back below 70
in terms of the percent of bitcoin that
is in profit and so it's an important
level to understand as you think about
what could happen next and then of
course if we look at the whales what the
hell are the whales doing well there's
still a lack of large buyers what do we
mean
the whales on chain those entities with
over a thousand bitcoin they simply are
not buying in any material way it's
basically just going sideways you can
see here with this green line the
holders or the whale holders they simply
are just going sideways so even though
price is going up and down we still are
just seeing sideways movement in order
for us to see a material move in price
upwards what you can see is that usually
there's an uptick in whale activity the
whales start buying and then price
follows of course it's a finite supply
asset and if there's an increase in
demand then that leads to an increase in
price but while we are watching the
whale's simply just going sideways it
means that we shouldn't expect to see
any material price movement upwards
until we see an uptick in that whale
activity and then if we go and we look
at the future start looking at some of
these derivatives the more exotic
products what you can see is that the
three-month basis for futures is down
roughly six percent it means that you
can long the spot market and short the
three-month bitcoin futures contract and
you'll capture approximately a six
percent annualized yield that is far
from the 45 percent yield that you are
pulling in last spring but it beats
point six percent that you can get from
a one-year treasury bond will just
absolutely crushing it on this analysis
and so as you see that drawdown all the
way back from april and may of last year
up around 40 45 percent as we've come
down now sitting around six percent it
just deters some of the interest that we
were seeing in q1 and q2 of last year
and so again that doesn't mean that the
interest won't return it doesn't mean
that the interest is gone forever it
just simply means that right now if you
go ahead and you pull on this cash and
carry trade which you basically are
pulling is about six percent but you at
one point we're pulling 45 percent it's
important to understand why some people
may be allocating or not allocating to
the actual market and then ultimately if
we go ahead and we look at the weekly
close as will points out there's still
three days left before that weekly close
and a weekly close believe below 40k
leaves no clear levels of support before
the 3 000
or i'm sorry the 30 000 area and so
ultimately as you look at this here you
can see we had rolled all the way up
about sixty thousand dollars or so and
then we crashed in may back down to
around thirty thousand dollars that
thirty thousand dollar level ended up
serving as a really really strong
support
from there then what we got was a rally
all the way back up to 69 000 and now
we've come back down below 40. so
ultimately that weekly close is going to
be really important do we close above 40
000 or do we have the weekly close below
40 000. if it is below 40 000 there's a
high likelihood that we could see
something in the low 30 thousands again
nobody knows the future history does not
serve as a predictor of the future but
what we can do is we can look at how
this asset has behaved previously now
one of the things that i'm personally
very interested is the idea that bitcoin
specifically is a volatile asset in us
dollar terms we saw over six different
times in 2021 where bitcoin drew down
more than 20 percent
there was a 50 percent drawdown in
bitcoin's price in 2018. there's a 50
percent drawdown on a bitcoin's price in
2020. there's a 50 drawdown in bitcoin's
price in 2021
and now that we're seeing a sell-off of
bitcoin in 2022
just understand this is not new you
don't have to panic you don't have to
freak out what you do have to understand
though is exactly how this asset
performs and understand as best you can
as to why it's performing the way that
it is
a lot of folks over the last two years
or so that previously didn't hold
bitcoin that work at large wall street
institutions or the institutions or
organizations themselves they started to
adopt bitcoin started to buy it and they
thought that they were long-term holders
but they treat the asset like a risk
asset and so as they fear the fed's
interest rate hikes that that cheap
capital become more expensive in the
market and that some of the unleashed
demand will actually dry up a little bit
they start to sell those risk assets
they rotate their capital from risk on
to risk off they want the value stocks
they want the value investing they want
the conservative investments they want
to risk mitigate and so if you're on
wall street if you're an institution if
you're a large asset manager
bitcoin to use the most risky thing you
own
your seller you're not trying to hold it
you simply treat it like a growth stock
or a tech stock
but bitcoiners
those are in my opinion the most
important people because we just hit an
all-time high in bitcoin holders that
have a bitcoin address with a balance of
at least .01 bitcoin it's an all-time
high bitcoin miners the hash rate just
hit an all-time high the underlying
fundamentals the bitcoin natives they're
undeterred by the price movement in fact
they're continuing to stack sets they're
continuing to secure the network and
ultimately what we have is we have price
completely diverging from reality of the
bitcoin fundamentals
and over a long enough period of time
price and fundamentals have to meet
again the question is just what's going
to happen between now and then and how
long will that take
so i hope that you guys enjoy this
and we'll continue to keep looking at
the data we'll will be back next week
and my guess is he's going to have a
bunch to update us on